So now that our character animation is done and added to our sequence, it's time to create our Cinema Camera actor
so that when the sequence plays that you see through the camera that we're creating and not the player's viewport.
So there are a couple different ways that we could go about this. Now, let's go back to our sequence.
I'm going to roll up my SKM bot.
The first and easiest is we could just click this button to create a new camera and set it as the current camera tracks,
which is what we will do.
The second option is we could actually create a Cinema Camera actor, so an actual actor in our level,
and adjust our settings and then right-click add it to our sequence.
Now where you may want to choose this option of adding the actual Cinema Camera to your level
is a couple different reasons. If there's a very specific look or feel you have for the camera,
so say for example we change it from
16 by 9 digital film to IMAX, or maybe we're using various different lens settings for ultra-wide cinematic,
etc. As opposed to just creating a new default camera, you may want to repurpose a camera that's already in your level.
That is absolutely fine. Totally a doable thing.
Again, all you need to do is add the camera to the level, right-click, and then add the actor to the sequence.
So let's go ahead and delete this.
I'm just going to go back down to sequence and click our little camera button.
So now we get our camera actor, and we get our camera cuts track, which is set up and ready to go.
Now one thing to note real quick about my viewport, yours may or may not look different here.
In particular, if you notice that I have the UI here for our timeline, our playback controls,
the actual camera information, and the sequence that we're in.
If yours looks like this, so the default viewport, and you don't have those controls,
that's simply because you're viewing through the default viewport.
So if we go up to our perspective and change this to our cinematic viewport, of course it will change.
We'll go down to our camera cuts track and simply just toggle this view through, and now
we have our viewport. So now we can see our character, we have our playback controls, and we are ready to rock and roll.
All right, so let's go back to our start here, and what we want to do is just build this camera up
to the way that we want to animate it. Now if you notice that if I right click in my viewport,
and I can't move my camera, to move the camera I could, you know, activate my viewport here,
use a, if we go to perspective, and we are cinema locked here, but I could use another viewport
and try to adjust it, but I'll show you another and easier way to do this. So instead of
selecting our camera cuts track, if we select our cinema camera actor, we're actually viewing
and we're piloting the cinema camera actor. So now I can move the camera and it will record
all of its information. So for this shot, I think I want to have the character kind of just run off
screen, I'll have the camera move with it. Now this is a little bit tighter angle
than what I want, so I can select my cinema camera actor from the sequence, go over to our
details panel, and now what I can do is like change my focal length to something like maybe 22
to get us a wider angle, move the camera forward. Now I am using just the standard kind of viewport
movement control, so just right clicking and then W, A, S, and D, and just get my camera into position.
All right, so this should be good to go. Same thing as we animated our character,
put out of my cinema camera actor, and under my transform just hit the little plus button
to add a key, and then we'll go all the way to the end of our shot, and what I want to do is
just have the camera just kind of move forward just slightly so we have some movement here,
a dolly shot of sorts. So if I go back to the beginning, you'll see it created my keyframe,
we'll hit play, now we've got that camera movement following the character as he runs and jumps.
Now quick thing, I like the slow down movement here, but because we're opening the shot just
kind of out of the gate, you may or may not want to change the opening keyframe here to linear,
now if we go back you'll see that the motion just starts the camera, and then it will slow down
towards the end. Perfect, I think that is good to go. All right, so the last thing that we need to do
is you'll notice that the character is out of focus and the background is in super focus,
this is not what we want. So what I'm going to do is actually select my cinema camera actor,
and in the focus settings I'm going to click the draw, debug, focus settings, I'll kind of move
this out a little bit, the focus plane, and you'll notice it's way off screen, but if I left click and
drag, see it'll bring it into focus where camera is actually focused. You could do this
manually or you could click the little eyedropper and select the character, you'll see that it
snaps, now in this case I'm just going to push it just a little bit forward. All right,
so now if I turn off my draw, debug, focus plane, you see now the background is blurred
and the character is more in focus. Now we could go into more depth on how to
track this so that it always stays in focus on the character, this is a simple shot, not super
concerned about it. One other thing that you may want to change is the depth of field, so right
now our current aperture is set to 2.8. So if I decrease this to say something like 1.2,
you'll notice that it gets more fuzzy. Now if I increase the aperture to say something like 22,
you'll see that most of the scene is in focus. So I'm going to undo that, go back to our 2.8,
because I do like the cinematic feel of this look, but just know that you can change that
setting to get more or less focus of your elements. All right, go back to our beginning
here, double check that this is in focus, our character moves, runs, jumps, looks great.
All right, perfect. Save our sequence, and so now we have our camera and our character
all nested within our sequence, and we're ready to move on to the next part.